how do we connect snowflakes fractals
the brain computes what where where's
this all-star so we're gonna have a look
at fractals we first of all have to
define what the heck is a fractal that's
the first thing we need to do I'll show
you some examples in nature and then I
want to try and connect that to pretty
recent research that's been going on in
terms of what are called neuromorphic
structures trying to have devices trying
to have computing architectures which
are much more aligned with how our brain
computes and the perhaps more correctly
much more in line with how our brain is
wired and the ability for our brain to
make new connections to be plastic to
make different connections there's a
whole burgeoning whole really developing
area of research which is incredibly
exciting in terms of trying to take that
type of process and that type of dynamic
and embed it in sort of inorganic
systems
we said in the last video what does a
computer do well it takes in information
and does something to that information
and outputs other information sort of
what we do we take in a huge range of
sensory inputs we do something to them
which results in some output we do
something we feel something etc so it's
a question about how that information is
processed and of course we don't have
CMOS up here we don't have incredibly
regimented and well-organized top-down
sculpted pieces of silicon and do all
the processing up here were a mess
particularly I'm particularly a mess but
if you look at the structure of the
brain it's incredibly branched and
incredibly dendritic lots of different
pathways if you look at a nerve cell you
look at a neuron very fingery and very
branched etcetera almost random it looks
like certainly not like a very rigid
grid like type structure as we have with
CMOS so the question then is you know
what's happening in terms of the just
how the brain processes information and
of course you know you have incredibly
good incredibly powerful pieces of
silicon technology that can you know I
perform us in so many ways but then you
ask it to distinguish between a
Chihuahua and a blueberry muffin and it
gets completely screwed so where we went
out so what is it about how we process
information I'd love to say we're going
to address that question we're not quite
but we're going to certainly look at the
role of sort of fractal and dendritic
structures so basically what is a
fractal what is a dendritic structure
and why are they important in
information processing first-year
student here in physics of nottingham
noah Hardwicke come in give me a
Christmas card which was very very nice
of him but what I did not first realize
is that this is a computer-generated
Christmas card all the code is in here
and moreover it's unique there was no
other Christmas card like this you'll
have much the same structure another
Christmas cards but it would be very
slightly different because all of these
features the snowflakes the ferns
the trees are fractal in nature and he's
generated them with a piece of code and
every time it'll be slightly different
so it is truly a unique Christmas card
so it's very happy to get that not least
because Sean and I had been planning
this video is a very timely
Christmas card to get snowflakes are
incredibly interesting there's a hole
this is a paper from 30 years ago from I
believe yeah 1987 from 30 years ago
there's still a huge amount of debate as
to how snowflakes form what is the
underlying structure but what's
important in this paper and in number of
subsequent papers is that they've used a
very simple relatively simple computer
simulation to model just how snowflakes
grow and running in the background here
is a simulation called a diffusion
limited aggregation simulation I didn't
write it it's actually written by one of
the first-year students here again guy
called Jimmy Mayer I do a lecture just
at the start of first semester when the
first years arrive and on chaos and
various different aspects of chaos and
one of those is related to fractals
which we are getting to slowly and Jamie
but I mentioned in the in the lecture
well if you really want to understand
something coded and that's exactly what
Jamie did and he's developed this
simulation whereby what you have is lots
and lots of little particles they could
be water molecules or ice particles from
for example they're moving around and we
have a really simple rule a really
simple rule basically it moves around it
follows a random walk which just means
it's it's equal probability of going
north south east it's not right no
east-west and so it follows that around
it's also called a drunkards walk
because you're just stumbling around all
over the place and if it hits another
particle it sticks and it doesn't
disconnect and then what happens is that
sticks and then the next particle moves
around that sticks and that sticks and
that sticks and gnostics and it becomes
very higgledy-piggledy but what's
interesting is it becomes very
higgledy-piggledy but with a very
specific type of structure it's random
each time we run it but the overall
characteristics and the statistics are
the same time and time again and it's
called a fractal structure if you look
at it you see this branching and if you
look for these patterns in nature you
find them everywhere obviously ferns
trees riverbeds a great deal of it stems
from the work of Mandelbrot and many of
you will have heard of the Mandelbrot
set the important thing in yours is why
is it called a fractal
so fractal is actually short
for fractional dimension so what does a
fractional dimension mean so we got a
line okay you can move in that direction
back and forth it's one-dimensional if
you got an area square
it's two-dimensional if you've got a
cube three-dimensional the problem is
what about this it's not a close-packed
structure it's not a line but then it's
also not a closed enclosed volume or a
closed area it's somewhere in between
the two and actually if we work it
through we find that it's it can be
defined in terms of having a fractional
dimension somewhere between one day or
2d or in other cases between 2d and 3d
I'm looking at and saying to me it looks
like it's a 2d structure that so it's
it's a 2d structure but how do we
actually define this dimension is a
special type of dimension is a very good
question so what we need to do is think
about just how we break this structure
down or just how we would form a
structure like this or any other
structure from building blocks so let's
take a line and I've run out of room let
me start again you may need to cut an
awful lot of this out you'll see he'll
ruler
thank you without wanting to cut to the
punch line but is this gonna be about
how many blocks it takes actly so this
is all about scalability and it's all
about a concept which is basically self
similarity and that's very important
when comes to fractals so here we've got
a line and we can break that line up
into well as many pieces as we like but
let's just keep three for simplicity so
each one of those is exactly the same
shape it's not only self-similar it's
identical apart from a scaling size so
how many pieces are we got there we've
got three and we've got one dimension
similarly here now we've got two
dimensions but we're going to divide
this up into into a series of blocks
I've got 1 2 3 in that direction 1 2 3
in that direction so we've got 9 and
that's two dimensions here we've got 27
and that's three dimensions now we can
see a pattern here
three this fairly straightforward is
equal to 3 to the power of 1
9 is equal to 3 to the power of 2/3 or
dimension 1 dimension 2 dimensions
27 is equal to 3 to the power of 3 so
there's our dimension okay so that's
fine
those are usual objects were very
familiar with those how do we do what
what what is that how would we write
down its dimensionality what's the
what's the self similar bit so we could
start without but let's let's not want
one thing we could do is we could
measure the ratio or the perimeter to
the area that's certainly one way to
knit those objects are pretty
well-defined and boring incredibly
boring we're gonna look at something
called a Koch's snowflake I'm not gonna
try and measure this out because it'll
just take too long so just bear with me
I'm gonna use a pencil in case I make a
mistake so you start off with an
equilateral triangle and then what you
do is you again divide this up into
three and you put another triangle in
there with that's now your side length
so these are all equilateral triangles
and then you put another one over here
just losing the lines yes we're just
losing the lines so largely because what
we want is to have a continuous line so
now haven't got rid of those there's our
first generations snowflake then you do
the same thing again divide this up into
three put you in equilateral triangle in
there and then similarly here and here
and here and here
repeat repeat repeat repeat repeat and
what you end up with is something that
is pretty well drawn on the wiki page so
of a triangle do that break it up break
it up again break it up again break it
up again what's remarkable is that now
if you follow this process through and
keep going this the the the line length
here never converges so what you'll end
up with is an infinitely long line in a
finite area which is a fairly compared
to these very boring objects which are
finite finite finite finite both in in
length and area here we have something
which is
when you stand it out and you kept going
with our process you'd have an
infinitely long line in a finite area
the important thing is that the
perimeter length doesn't converge so it
really is if you follow this to its
natural limit or your honda earned or
whether something that's infinitely long
but it's in a finite area so looking at
that you're saying that it's constrained
in an hour is that because it kind of
like the angles work so that it just
keeps working back on itself exactly so
it's it's confined it's not diverging
over that area it's constrained with
enough that within that area just due to
exactly due to the geometry and I we
could work this through if we just take
this so if we look at that relationship
what we have is that the number of
pieces n is equal to the scale factor s
because what we've done is we've taken
this and broken it down into three to
the power of the dimension so the number
of pieces in this case 27 is the scale
factor because we broke it down into
three in all three dimensions to the
power of three for this one n would be
equal to 27 this is going to be a long
video short home geez s is going to be
equal to three that's our scale factor
and D is our dimensionality is going to
be equal to three now we're gonna have
to do some maths or math depending on
which side of the pond you you livin
what we have here is n is equal to s to
the power D now if we take logs some of
you might remember logs what we'll find
is log N and one of the wonderful
properties of logs is that raising to a
power becomes a multiplication in Log
land is equal to D times log s so I make
sense you say log ya log at the number
of blocks is equal to the dimension
times the log of the scale factor okay
they say it's going somewhere let's put
that up here right so that's fine for
these and when you work that through you
find out that or let's actually go the
next step just a 1 one more line of
maths to work out what D is let's divide
both sides by log s so log n divided by
log s divided here by log S we obviously
and what you find is if you work this
process through and I encourage you to
do so then you find that you will get an
integer value for the dimension what
happens if we do it to the snowflake so
we'll start off with a line now we're
going to divide it up into 3 and then
remember
we take our equilateral triangle and if
I can draw that correctly we put that
equilateral triangle there and then we
get rid of that but the important thing
is we've taken a line and we divide it
in three
didn't matter it that's made that line
longer in it does and you're not sure
well you are jumping the gun but you're
jumping the gun in an exceptionally good
way because that's exactly where I'm
going so we're divided in three but
we've actually got four units now so one
two three four remember this is an
equilateral triangle so we've got it we
divided it in three but we've got four
units make sense so now our n is equal
to four
but our s is equal to three not good you
know I like so that means that D is
equal to log four over log three we've
decided that what we're going to do in
terms of how we're going to make this
pattern is we're going to have a scale
factor of three so each each individual
line is a third of the original length
but we're just gonna set up our geometry
so we need four of those lines okay and
if you work out then what the dimension
is you'll find that that's something
like 1.2 it's not an integer
it's a fractional dimension so that's
fractals that's where it comes from it's
it's we probably had to do too much
maths but we've done a little bit but as
you can see the beauty of maths the
beauty and power of math is you get so
much out of it so if we went then to the
next level we would obviously put a
triangle in the middle of here but we're
doing the same process again and would
that increase it no so it's the same
process time and time again so you only
have to do it at this level because
you're asking yourself at each level and
the important thing is itself similar so
you can you can look at it in a growth
scale and then you can zoom in and zoom
in overall you're gonna see the same
structure so now we've connected the
snowflake wonderful festive snowflake to
the mathematics and a computing let's
explore that in a little bit more detail
because when you look for these fractal
things they're right across nature in
fact a physicist what we tend to look
for is very ordered and I'm a physicist
I'm sort of interloping here in
computerphile
but I'm definitely a physicist we tend
to look for very ordered things very
structured things crystals we spend so
much of our life thinking about crystals
and how atoms are incredibly
well-ordered etc but in fact if you look
across the answer that's not what it's
like at all
we you know those incredibly crystalline
structures you know were not crystalline
if we were crystalline would be
incredibly boring if we were crystalline
then you wouldn't have the randomness
that you need for evolution you wouldn't
have the randomness that you need for
information transfer etc so crystalline
and very ordered structures are the
exception rather than the rule which
makes these type of structures
fascinating
so fractals can contain more and more
and more I'm trying not to use the word
data but I'm going to use the word data
data in one same contained area is this
something we can use for memory so
that's a fascinating question thank you
for that sure that brings me to this
wonderful structure some of you might be
familiar with this it's called the
Mandelbrot set I hope some of you from
any of that if you're not familiar with
the Mandelbrot set just stop listening
to me drone on go and look it up go and
spend a few hours so I'm not gonna go
into the details of the algorithm wiki
is actually again pretty good in terms
of the Mandelbrot set and you if you
google Mandelbrot set you will find
beautiful image upon beautiful image
upon beautiful image this is what it
looks like and it's actually a process
that happens on the complex plane
involving imaginary numbers but we don't
need all that detail important thing is
that you have a grid and in each point
in that grid you do a particular
algorithm it's a particular you can even
see you set it up in a while loop you
keep that running and you basically let
that run until it reaches a certain
limit and what you find is when you do
that process you get this incredible
structure you get all this complexity
coming out of an algorithm which
involves nothing more than squaring a
number and an addition that's all it
involves and yet you get all this
incredible complex details so complexity
from something very straightforward that
would be good enough you look at this
and it's you know it's it's incredible
you can see the sort of almost snowflake
dendritic structure again the branching
it's a mathematical landscape and then
if you zoom in to this particular region
I've just taken out at random you start
to see this little bit more like the
snowflake structure by the way this is a
piece of code I wrote using something
called LabVIEW a number of years ago in
fact I rolled it so long ago I couldn't
find the original code and it also gives
you an idea of just how disorganized I
am but we zoom in again and looked
snowflakes everywhere we see the same
type of fractal structure
and we can keep going and we can keep
going and we can keep going on we can
keep going forever forever
it never stops as long as you've got
enough computing power you can do this
till the end of the end of time and it
would never stop yet you can code it in
five lines if you're a better program
than me probably three lines it's it's
remarkable so when you think about that
in terms of information if we were to
take every individual pixel here and try
and cold it and store it we need just no
vast amounts of memory but we can
capture that in five lines or less it's
it's mind-blowing when you think about
so finally how does that all connect
back to the brain which is where we came
in
back in physics world in March you can
see coding and computing it were finally
starting to get computer scientists and
physicists to talk together a heck of a
lot more than they used to do there's a
great article in here a number of great
articles but there's some Jessamyn
fairfield he used to work in john
Bolin's group in Trinity College in
Dublin is now in Galway see the articles
called smarter machines and she talks
about the work that she was involved in
in in Bolin's group and dublin of work -
she drove so usually when we think about
nano electronics when we think about
trying to get faster capacities and more
computing power we think about being
very regimented and very controlled in
terms of how we we have ordered
structure in the surface and we'll use
lithography and billion-dollar plants to
really do this very very fine machining
what they do is they sort of chuck a
load of nano wires so they take a
solution not that different from this
put it on a surface let it dry and you
get a higgledy-piggledy net or mesh of
wires all connecting against each other
and again it's an open structure it's
not an incredibly close packed lots and
lots of different connections that can
form and that gives rise doing really
fascinating properties including the
ability for the network to rewire itself
and that's something our brain does our
brain is incredibly plastic in terms of
forming connections and it also has a
multitude of connections that branch off
much like the sort of fractal structures
we've been looking like this the
question of whether the brain is
fractal is again something that's been
debated at length time and time again
but it certainly has that large range of
different connections that we don't have
in the type of technology silicon
technology that underpins we have so
much of our world our brains are sort of
more along these lines and they call
this neuromorphic a neuromorphic device
because it's mimicking the type of or
hoping to mimic the type of process that
happens in our brains look into that
picture and the way you've just
described it they're creating wires in
some sense but without any purpose not
any purpose but they're just a bunch of
wires and they don't know what they do
precisely yes so instead of is it's like
my wiring curbs which is full of old
faux no leads and things and if I just
put some power in it hopefully it might
start thinking perhaps I wouldn't be
that extreme if your way when corporate
become sentient you're on the way to a
Nobel Prize let's put it that way just
keep quiet about it but don't let it get
to sentient that wouldn't be good this
is like a ground-up way of exactly using
something rather than being an architect
and saying this is where the foundations
will be here's what I've got I will work
with that that's exactly it so instead
of being constrained by I need to put
this here and this here and I need to
have this interconnect here and I've got
to worry about leakage and I've got a
how will that fit with the particular
blueprint I have let's throw away the
blueprint just throw some stuff down and
let's say well what function does it
give me and if it doesn't give me a
function well let's move on to the next
one throw some more stuff down and
that's a refreshing way to think it's
not an engineering where to think it's
more by a biological way to think it's
hard to understand that this would ever
work at all it does some remarkable
things in terms of they can train not
just this group or a number of groups
across the world you can train these
things to to recognize certain pulse
sequences for example just in terms of
what they're being fed in terms of
signals so it's yeah it's it's very much
in its infancy
in fact as although it's very much in
his infancy there's a massive project
which is created and generated a huge
amount of controversy called the human
brain project which is an eu-funded
projects over 1 billion euros we have
interviewed professor Stephen Ferber
the human brain project is wonderful so
let's put a link down there yeah and
using a million ARM chips
it was the thinking then I don't know
where that's gone we haven't yeah yeah
we were to check them but I know they
were thinking about a range of different
strategies and possibilities and I think
as far as I understand that one of those
was a little bit more along the lines of
this neuromorphic approach I could be
wrong I'm sure I would be corrected at
length and repeatedly in the comments
section if I am wrong and I look forward
to that very much this is a bit Ong
let's not critique me too much and so
yeah be very different ooh the originals
and the important thing is that we don't
know what went into here right we know G
but we don't know a and we can't find
the motion which is comparable to the
type of effects we have to consider when
we're thinking about black holes